the return of a familiar face Merrill
chef Jewish a man of many aspects
currently Commissioner for relations
between the EU institutions then
nominated Commissioner for transport and
space changed last week after the
resignation of another Commissioner
designate to vice president responsible
for energy union first mr. chef Javitch
laid out his ambitions I will address
the issue of energy security with the
utmost attention the time for a European
energy union has clearly come central to
that is to wean Europe which currently
spends 400 billion euros a year on
energy imports of foreign energy
particularly gas from Russia which he
said too often uses energy for its own
political leverage Russia is
increasingly using gas supply as an
instrument of pressure and as a
political weapon against Ukraine and
other countries who want to help her and
this is totally unacceptable and the
thought - for good housekeeping at home
and diversification of energy sources
energy efficiency has to be perceived
more as a first energy source the
cleanest megawatt is that one saved an
energy efficiency should be
significantly enhanced beyond 2020 I
want to continue the successful
production of greenhouse gas emissions
we need to be ambitious with our targets
for 2030 and I'm fully committed to make
the EU the world number one in renewable
energies specific questions - mr. chef -
rich from MEP s demanded more specific
answers do you see that combating
climate change is the threat to
economical growth in Europe
thank you I believe that both the
competitive industry and competitive
green policies must reinforce each other
from the greens confusion over who now
will represent the EU in a year of key
climate negotiations culminating in the
UN's global climate summit in Paris at
the end of next year one very simple
specific question
who is going to negotiate on behalf of
the European Commission in the
international climate negotiations if
the question is who goes to Paris so
that I can assure you that I will go to
Paris but their old de Paris is rather
long first thing before paris deciding
on europe's position on the next phase
of co2 reduction targets with many
pressing for a strict 40% or higher
Kamisha when it will be preparing its
negotiating position for Paris will be
will be very ambitious in this regard as
well next stage and what has been a long
process of commissioner designate
hearings a decision on Tuesday in hi
hope that the following day MEP s can
vote on president-elect jean-claude
yonkers entire College of Commissioners